on this episode I get over my football
loss hangover and drill some really hard
questions right in the face
[Music]
this is
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 145 of
the askgaryvee show
Monday morning gloomy in the city when I
got up this morning which makes sense
stunwin super pumped of you you were
converting you into a sports fan that's
freaking me out probably freaking
breathe probably freaking you out more
it gets emotional right that late
interception you were upset that was
wrong d-roc you also are becoming a fan
fan just about the other football team
you watch the Jets to India all right
I'm in I'm in a bad mood but not as bad
as I thought I think it comes down to
the fact that you guys saw Stefan edit
this in this prediction last week
official prediction time this one's
gonna hurt
I have a feeling that Dekker and ivory
are not playing I'm uh I think the
Eagles are playing for their lives I
think that the Jets I I don't think the
Jets have never beaten the Eagles in NFL
history and a regular season game and
and I'm very very concerned to this I'm
still very affected by the 1994 93 94
game where the Jets were up 21-7 against
the Eagles at home and an Eric Allen had
a 99 yard interception return for a
touchdown as the Jets were about to go
up 28 to 7 and Johnny Mitchell's
coming-out party game
Eagles went on to win there's just
something bad about this game I'm taking
a ton of vaynermedia Eagle fan employees
Mark Evans and Brandon Resnick and
Taggart and Lindsay price I think I'm
bringing too many employees to the game
that feels wrong and I think the Jets
the Jets stumble here I think that I I
think they stumble here unfortunately
I'm gonna go Eagles 20 Jets 16
hurts my feelings to go that route but
that's that's my official prediction I'm
not gonna predict them to win every week
I will not be surprised if they win I
feel nice that they could win but my
official prediction is that Jets stumble
this week 22:16 kind of like the whole
thing like 3040 seconds kind of thing so
I've been really on point with my Jets
predictions this year I'm three for
three most people didn't think they were
going to beat the Colts I was right
about that most people didn't think they
wouldn't lose the Eagles I was right
about that but I'm feeling pretty good
early on for London
speaking of London I think I've got a
busy schedule but I feel a little
motivated to maybe pull off a show on
Friday or Saturday morning but d-roc in
the comments on Facebook and YouTube or
Twitter hit up the rock you rock take
control of this find a a sane awesome
skilled recorder I don't want to make I
don't to do a live show my uncle my
parents are coming to London I never get
to spend time with them they never
travel we took two family vacations so
as much as I love the vaynernation in
the UK I need to milk every second I
have with them plus I'll be in Jets mode
but I can be motivated to bang out a
twenty minutes show and so one one
person maybe couldn't have an India
seems like everybody wants your job
anyway maybe two people can play the
role that so I may sneak in a Friday or
Saturday recording for a show
no not I'm feeling good like your
sticker India let's get into the show
all right let's do it
excited focused ready Lachlan asks I'm
new to medium how do I build a community
on it the jab jab jab and hopefully
someone notices cheers bro cheers bro I
think the great thing about medium one
of the reasons I invested in it one of
the reasons we write for it is you
actually just have to put out good
content because they're doing two things
that are intriguing one there's a viral
loop people sharing recommending it at
the bottom I was one of the early people
to growth hack a little bit and ask for
the hit the recommend which created
virality the but they also use human
editors who just see a good piece of
content and populate it to the email to
the top of the page
this is an incredible opportunity my
friends medium in a lot of ways has read
it and dig dynamics that we haven't seen
in a long time where you could be
anybody you don't have to just juice
using the juice of your social networks
to get people there but you can be
anybody who writes a good solid piece of
content and then the machine not the
community humans can decide to populate
it and give you an opportunity to then
siphon the really Holy Grail for a lot
of you and the reason I'm pushing so
many of you in the vaynernation to write
on it is you can write a nice piece of
content get lucky but probably not lucky
because it was a good piece of content
but a little serendipity along with that
good piece of content and now you're
populated you get a you know couple
hundred a couple thousand people follow
you off of the base of that being
featured and away you go you start
building and so that's for people with
no audience for all of you that are
lucky enough to have some Facebook some
Twitter some Instagram followers and
users you should put out content there
and use that as an opportunity to be
discovered and so you know I used
Facebook very successfully to drive
people towards medium email services to
drive people towards medium which then
gets people reading and recommending
which creates more virality which gets
more people to recognize me and it
becomes this viral loop so it's not
about Jab Jab Jab right hook where
that's a world of put out put out put
out content and then ask for something
this is more about just putting out good
content and letting the chips fall where
they may
I think the other thing you can do is go
out to other people that have audiences
or other publications that may then want
to republish a publication that has a
link that says this was originally
written in medium and that's links and
so you're trying to create viral loop
because the recommend at the bottom of
medium creates virality within medium
there's a big audience there and that's
where your opportunity lies very
tactical off the gate on a Monday
morning Steven asks how do I create
value in the services I provide for
clients in the same market while
respecting their competitive advantage
that's interesting and and we kind of
play with that a little bit with
vaynermedia not that we have any direct
competitors but sometimes there's some
nuances providing value to different
companies or individuals that are
competing in the same environment is
tricky first of all you know I would
never be an environment of like Pepsi
and Coke
or you know where there's complete
direct competitors you've got to be very
very very careful number two I think
that you need to really really give
thought about how many different thesis
--iz and strategies do you actually have
how many different things can people do
this is where you cannot just put one
kind of blueprint and deploy it against
each client you've got to come up with
unique value propositions creatively and
strategically that allow them to kind of
offset their competitive set I think the
answer is very carefully I think this is
a massive challenge and I think that um
I think that one of the things that I
would recommend to you is actually
brought in the industries you're in just
for that reason because I think that
humans are emotional and they may not
even if you think that you're providing
them separate value you you know they
may not and the consumers perception is
king but I think to me it's not that
hard because I do think you can give
very different strategies very different
creative executions amongst those
strategies to make an action that those
companies or individuals want to happen
I think the bigger problem is those
individuals feeling as though that is
happening and that's the vulnerability
of your actual business perception my
friends is absolutely reality because
that's what people are making judgements
on I mean who else is making the reality
is a reality decision there's no reality
Lord that comes down there's no reality
Lord perception is reality because
humans perception is their reality
they're making decisions in that and
that is the vulnerability in that
question I can't wait to see the
graphics of it you better forget reality
Lord I want that again what I just did
it I want it there too I mean I want
it's gonna be and I don't want that I
don't want you to do the editing for
that to you you might have added that so
share it with him
[Music]
Clinton asks one time I farted in math
class and everyone for us to figure out
who did it
do you have an embarrassing moment I do
have an embarrassing moment story in
second grade this is a classic so one of
the moments I realized how amazing my
mom was I'll get to that punch line at
the end mom I know you're watching these
shows I don't know when the last time
you thought about this was because we
don't talk about a lot in second grade
just normal day in second grade just
doing my thing we got to the Pledge of
Allegiance and got to the Pledge of
Allegiance and I really had to go to the
bathroom and and so I've been known my
whole man long until my 13 14 15 I would
hold if I had a pee I would hold my pee
pee to like make sure I wouldn't pee and
so in second grade I'm doing that
because I have to go to the bathroom
and I'm at my desk and remember the
desks that had the whole thing and so
you know like you have the chair you had
to go in like this
you know go in like this and then like
the desk was here right you're like
little right so I'm to the right of it
does the part here and we have to do the
Pledge of Allegiance and so because I I
did like I because I guess I didn't
realize I could hold my pee pee with my
left hand when I went for the right hand
I decided to press my peepee against the
chair this is a true story by the way
and to make sure I wouldn't pee that was
unsuccessful and I peed all over my desk
and all over my pants and obviously
everybody heard the pain everybody
looked back I'm like a fart there was
yes Matt I'm like do I get my new phone
awesome don't know what well last time
we had a weird is so bad okay yes
obviously unlike a fart where you could
be like India did it this was pretty
obviously there's a big PETA thing goes
weren't like pancita and so I had to go
to the nurse and I went home and when my
mom picked me up she told me the story
of how my dad wants peed in class which
I found out later was not true
but she tried to make me feel better big
kudos to mrs. VA's Nueske's second-grade
class I am flabbergasted of how little
flak I had a take for that event
it was sky I went home change came back
to school good job in my mom to not
letting me do what I want to do it just
stay home I was stunned by the lack of
being made fun of for it show a lot of a
lot of maturity in that 1983-84
second-grade class so that is my
embarrassing story moment feels like
there could be a really funny visual
t-shirt made up have finished out
t-shirt of an eight year old you peeing
on a chair it's out there by the way it
was absolutely crazy like like I peed on
top of the desk and it was like dripping
like I said it was a scene all right
Leland asks I have vodka energy it's an
alcoholic beverage but I don't drink how
do i market without telling lies Jesus
there's that I keep I don't somebody
look up this guy who invented the
Backstreet Boys and NSYNC
I think it's name it's not Ron Perlman
but it's it's similar kind of name you
know went to jail for fraud Lou Pearlman
yeah yep Lou Pearlman is a fat old 50
year old white guy that invented the two
biggest boy bands of the 90s and so he
wasn't a 14 year old girl he wasn't
listening to teeny Bop usik just because
you are not a consumer of your product I
write books and don't read them then so
this question is a piece of cake often
often the best creators of products are
people that are not the consumers of
that product so the way to not lie is to
not say that you actually drink your
product and that happens all the time
there is even look there's even a
classic you know quoting a very classic
statement that I believe in tremendous
never get high off your own supply
right like I mean I mean this is well
entrenched into our culture like you
don't have to use your thing or consume
your thing to be a reasonable voice
not to mention 19 don't get it twisted
by the way I live my life
99% of CEOs and owners and presidents
and and operators of companies are not
the front men and women of their
businesses like like you don't have me
the face of your company just be a
business person and hire somebody who
drinks vodka energy drinks which is oh I
don't know everybody on Instagram you
know it's so like like it's you know I
mean that's a very easy question who's
who ask that leyland that's a piece of
cake answer question question answer
Jesus Mike Mike via the podcast well you
know what let's do a podcast exclusive
tonight is this the guy who actual did I
see this right there's the guy who like
switched two and a half hour drive or
whatever or is that somebody yeah do I
do a good job paying attention to my
community India thank you thank you
India uh I don't know the answer is that
happens with me all the time like I stop
and start things all the time I love
when people like oh you said you were
always gonna get out and what like Jesus
Christ when you're innovating at scale
some things hit the ground and so it
lost momentum that's the answer to a
question and good news I'm gonna do one
after this episode because I feel guilty
okay great you feel good about yourself
yeah I'm guilt I feel guilty we'll do an
exclusive podcast question today Big Ups
to everybody on the treadmills and
driving in their trucks good make a
statement of the day interesting Monday
I adore all of you have a wonderful week
we'll be doing the show Tuesday we'll be
doing the show Wednesday are we doing
the show Thursday sneaking one in before
I go to London great and it looks like
maybe you try to do something Friday I'm
a business work with Eric full wire see
if you can figure out cuz I'm
London it's a business uh you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
bless you that's gonna be great keep
that with the black and white that's
amazing all right by the way you guys
have to see Hamilton oh yeah I saw so
you know what I'm talking about oh my
god I'm so pumped I get to meet the
person that told you about it you're
gonna hear all about it for the next
year and you'll be like oh my god Gary
was gonna tell me Hamilton is a play a
musical on Broadway that is unbelievable
it is about Alexander Hamilton and the
entire play is being wrapped one see if
you love history and you love hip-hop
you have to go it is bonkers is it the
one it's based on the rap the creator in
the house yeah but the white house
that's exactly what it isn't that that's
the one
yep that video is amazing so the whole
things like that that video is a piece
of dog [ __ ] compared to show guys
it's on elite you got the video Oh pull
up the video I just want to see Stefan
it's so it's that good it's great it's
great it's literally the first
turnaround received in the heights he
was he was born a penniless orphan in
st. Croix of illegitimate birth came
George Washington's right-hand man with
every other founding father and all on
the strength of his writing I think he
embodies yeah words ability to make a
difference so I'm gonna be doing the
first song for that tonight I'm
accompanied by Tony and Grammy winning
music director Alex Lac more
anything you need to know I'll be
playing a vice president Aaron Burr and
snap along if you like
there burden in the play some little how
does a bastard orphan son of before in
the scotsman dropped in the middle of
the forgotten spot of the Caribbean my
Providence impoverished this koala know
what to be a hero when the scholar the
$10.00 founding father without a father
got a lot father I worked in a lot part
of my being a lot smarter but being a
self-starter pop waters in charge of the
trader charter